let's go to the other side of the hill
and bring in nebraska republican senator
deb fischer of the senate armed services
committee discuss today's hearing as
well as what we just heard from chad
senator thanks for joining us thank you
brett i want to play this sound bite
what the president told george
stephanopoulos and what you heard some
of it today about the troop
recommendations take a listen
your military advisor did not tell you
no we should just keep 2500 troops no no
one said that to me that i can recall is
that true i know the president to be an
honest and forthright man was that a
false statement to the americans i'm not
going to categorize the statement of a
president united states you do not have
a duty to cover for the president when
he's not telling the truth was that a
false statement or not i've given you my
opinion on the matter i've given you my
judgment on it
uh senator both of those generals the
chairman of the joint chiefs and general
mckenzie said that they recommended 2500
troops remaining on the ground in
afghanistan as they put it up the chain
right you know presidents are elected
for reasons they make strategic
decisions general milley said that today
he also said that this was a strategic
failure president biden disregarded the
advice of his top generals he knew what
the risks were he knew what the
consequences would be and he went ahead
and made his own decision on this you
know that's a it's really a pattern
we've seen with the president bob gates
made the observation in his book that
joe biden in 40 years in the united
states senate was wrong on just about
every serious foreign policy or national
security decision and he was wrong on
this one he should have listened to his
generals and he's been
not honest with the american people on a
number of things one was the advice that
he did receive he wasn't honest about
that you heard that today another was
his his position
that we can maintain
the security of this country by not
being in afghanistan and keeping a force
there with the with counterterrorism and
that was more my line of questioning
yeah what do you say when democrats push
back and say it's the president's
decision they call this a bold decision
even if it was in the face of his
military advisers at choosing something
different
because we had to get out of this
20-year war and we had to get our troops
home one way or another how do you
respond to that i respond by saying we
can disagree
on if we should have ever been in
afghanistan we can disagree
on the withdrawal in setting a date on
that but the american people have seen
the how wrong his decision is this isn't
a bold decision it's a wrong decision on
how we withdrew our troops i had a
nebraskan
corporal page who was killed in
afghanistan he was one of the 13. this
is a wrong decision by this president
and instead of trying to gloss it over
and and make excuses and try to spin it
at a press conference you know why can't
we look at a way forward and make right
decisions in the future senator wicker
asked the chairman about credibility
around the world take a listen to this
answer
our credibility would be damaged our
credibility has has
been gravely damaged has it not general
milley i think that our credibility um
with allies and partners around the
world and with adversaries
is being intensely reviewed by them to
see which way this is going to go
and i think that damage is one word that
could be used yes
damage could be used senator where do
you think this is going in the eyes of
our allies around the world well i was
on a codel over in eastern europe and i
talked to some nato allies and what we
heard was yes our credibility has been
damaged we're looking at allies who are
questioning
who we are if we are firm in our
commitments if we're going to be there
for them
in the future
and i can tell you one question that i'm
not hearing is from the jihadists from
the terrorists they're not questioning
this they're they're inspired they are
out recruiting and i think if you talk
to uh anyone within the department of
defense and with this in the state
department if they're honest they'll
tell you that recruitment's up for the
terrorists and it puts our nation at
risk
there are some democrats and others in
the finance committee who believe that
our credibility as a as a nation uh
paying their bills is going to be
affected and you voted no to raise the
debt ceiling
this week
as did other republicans
you voted that way before we should
point out under the trump administration
but are you worried that we're pushing
the line here as far as the financial
credibility
we aren't pushing the line because the
democrats can do this on their own they
you know they can do it on their own
they are right now talking about human
infrastructure and the
a 3.5 trillion dollar wish list for
progressives you know if they can do
that on their own they can pay the bills
on their own for it
but
isn't this a bipartisan thing it's a
bill that we've already paid i mean
we've already used that money this is
money that republicans
authorized as well uh
under the trump administration some 7.8
trillion dollars of debt was added to
the bottom line you know if you look at
what happened in march brett
that was a complete democrat exercise
that 1.9 trillion dollars we're seeing
it again right now they are not reaching
out in a bipartisan way they are not
reaching out to republicans even trying
to work on some ideas here i heard you
say earlier about the democrats want to
have a transformational change here in
our country
they want to do that they should do it
on their own then and they should pay
the bills they should be honest about
the cost that we're going to incur that
taxpayers are going to face and this
idea
that it's free or this idea that nobody
who makes under 400 000 is going to pay
taxes look at what the stock market did
today people understand what's going on
here nothing's free
everybody's going to be taxed you look
at inflation going up that's a tax on
the middle class and it is a tax on
working americans but senator you can
see that both parties republicans and
democrats have been spending like
drunken sailors for years up on capitol
hill
you know i've said that before too and
then we get hit with coven yeah and and
we work together in a bipartisan way
trying to address that and we did spend
six trillion dollars but i think
republicans are saying you know we
didn't need to do that 1.9 trillion in
march because let's go back and see
where that other money has been spent on
and look at what's still available
what programs work that's the difference
you're seeing between the two parties
last thing now last thing quickly
senator senator bernie sanders
has said to house members on the
progressive side that if they vote on
this bipartisan infrastructure bill
thursday uh that they are losing all
leverage and he's saying don't vote on
that first you need to get the big 3.5
trillion dollar plan where do you sense
this is right now as we kind of go
minute to minute up there on the hill
yeah you know it is minute to minute we
we don't know where the democrats are on
this they're going to have to figure
that out themselves but to change horses
in midstream is maybe it's not unusual
in washington but when you're told one
thing and then you see leadership with
nancy pelosi in the house trying to
maneuver that fine line between her
moderates and the progressive wing of
the party you know we're just well i'm
just going to sit back and watch
senator deb fischer we appreciate your
time thanks